one of my favorite shows on TV is the
boys ah thanks and um I know that you
know Eric told me they're halfway
through filming season four right now
and diabolical I'm wondering what's
going on if that's going to get picked
up so I guess it's two-parter yeah is
there going to be more boys diabolical
and um what can you tease about season
four man I don't know if I can
necessarily tease anything about season
four other than like you know
just what I think I can't be more
shocked by what they're doing over there
they find a way to shock me even more
um and we have we have the college gen V
show which I've been starting to see
episodes of and it's
um completely insane
um and yeah I mean yeah just like the
combination of superheroes in a college
setting in an incredibly subversive
R-rated world is yeah there are parts of
that show where me and Evan are watching
the cuts of the sequences that were just
like dear God what if what are they
doing over there
um and I hope diabolical comes back
we've actually they they bought some
scripts for the next season so we've
been writing them we're not 100 sure
they will produce them but if everything
goes as planned they will produce the
scripts that that we are writing right
now that's actually great though because
um I think Amazon has done uh really
well with that and also Invincible you
know yeah that I've been working on too
I've been working on the next few
seasons of that and
um it's amazing also great which yeah
we're also producers on that so it's
they've been very supportive of letting
us do this crazy stuff it's truly uh
yeah we're doing sausage party with them
as well it's like they really um yeah
they really let us spend their money in
irresponsible ways